[Musik]
würde es nicht weiter vor nehmen das
crm-system ich bin gruppen kommandant
beim jägerbataillon 19 daran güssing
ich bin zuständig für die ausbildung der
rekruten
[Musik]
bin jetzt ein megawatt 19 und absolviert
meinen grundwehrdienst und bin jetzt in
vorbereitung für die
kaderpräsenzeinheiten
[Musik]
vollmann dann hinter mg
also indirekt bei der kaserne man
international ausgebauten checkpoint der
eigentlich alles bietet was man sich
wünschen kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben da ein kissinger riesenglück
mit unserer neu gebauten kaserne 2014
neu eröffnet wurde und bezogen wurde
[Musik]
wir können hier als rettungssanitäter
beim jägerbataillon 19
güssing als rettungssanitäterin vendor
in der dunklen ärztlichen ambulanz für
die versorgung der kultur diener
zuständig im gefechtes irgendwie
gemeinsam mit den kameraden den
abtransport von verletzten
[Musik]